ahora entrando de lleno a la encuesta
como tal que usted la título no sé si
definitivamente o por el momento la
integración social y económica de los
latinoamericanos en que ve que esa era
la intención de su investigación en que
se diferencia esta encuesta profesor
harmonie de una encuesta que hace
estadísticas canadá por ejemplo bueno
justamente yo uso mucho los datos de la
agencia federal de estadísticas y son
extremas extraordinariamente útiles
pero nos faltaba creo yo justamente este
perfil que va a buscar por un lado
algunos elementos más específicos pero
también de modo general lo que la gente
piensa o quiere o supone o evalúa
entonces así hacíamos preguntas como
cómo y de qué manera usted considera
satisfactorio y satisfactoria su vida
familiar social laboral etcétera
entonces con escalas de conformidad uno
puede mostrar después si hay una
tendencia hacia a tal o cual posición
mayor o menor satisfacción de vida vamos
a llamarla así está después también
todas las cuestiones sobre
identificación usted se siente más de
aquí más de su país de origen más
latinoamericano con quién tiene relación
amistosa en el trabajo de gente de su
propia comunidad queremos ver si el
latinoamericano por ejemplo un poco se
queda entre entre los suyos
culturalmente o lingüísticamente
hablando o si se abre al resto de la
sociedad entonces son factores que tiene
que ver con la vida de todos los días y
también con la manera en que el migrante
mismo percibe su a su trayectoria y sus
experiencias